Mel be sharing a shocking photo claiming
to have two broken ribs and a severed
hand this is a lot right now yes Gary
Spice gave her fans a scare on Instagram
early Monday and we're trying to figure
out what the hell happened
here's that pic again Mel after surgery
all sling dup outside the ER in London
she posted a lengthy caption but it
didn't really explain what happened to
her so here's what we do know she says
she had a three hour surgery to repair
damage to her right hand it seems safe
to assume Mel had some sort of bizarre
accident she included the hashtag
accidents happen in her caption the 43
year old also didn't say how long she's
been in the hospital it's obviously been
a minute though because she got a visit
from her fellow Spice Girls after the
surgery Mel shared this boomerang with
sporty baby and ginger she captioned the
cute moment when you're besties show up
to hospital with hugs laughter and a lot
of love I love my Spice Girls look we
all love these spices indeed now
hopefully Mel's injuries don't affect
the girl group or a Union tour it's not
said until next summer but Mel did have
to put her book tour on pause yeah I
know she's been busy promoting the
memoir brutally honest all over the
globe including with et right in this
book has been literally piecing the
puzzles together week by week and then
that happened after a year then that
happened after two years and when you
see all their Dow it's like oh my god I
shouldn't even be alive I shouldn't even
be mentally or emotionally like okay
with anything that's happened to me but
I have to start on my healing process of
my healing journey which is why this
book's so important to me and I have to
be able to talk about it because it's
not spoken about and it should be and it
should be spoken about in schools so
boys girls and young kids made aware I
would rather them read this book then
google my name and see all the lies and
the headlines which is so salacious and
so just not even doesn't even really
make sense I just sound like a crazy
woman
which is what an abuser would always
make
the abused person feel like like you're
crazy and no one's gonna believe you and
is what it is so just deal with it and
kind of make you a cup of tea after that
now et has learned Mel fell down a
flight of stairs at a friend's house
over the weekend and that drugs and
alcohol were not involved in the
accident it's unclear how much down time
she'll need to recover from the accident
she was set to be back in the States
this week today Mel says she's
absolutely gutted to have to cancel her
upcoming signings but she's got to quote
stay still to heal
we're gonna keep Mel's recovery in our
thoughts and keep an eye on this one
hopefully we'll have more details soon
stick with et online for all the latest
yep